bonsoir raphaël gauvin merci d'être avec
nous alors des années que ça dure
finalement cette situation pourquoi les
eurodéputés dont il au créneau
maintenant on va tout simplement parce
que ça a commencé en fait il ya une
dizaine d'années maintenant après la
crise financière de 2008 où les
américains au fait de plus en plus appel
à ses lois extraterritoriales donc la
loi extraterritoriale c'est là là c'est
une force de projection sceller les
américains imposent leur loi à
l'ensemble du monde l'exemple que vous
avez donnée de l'iran et est tout à fait
révélateur c'est à dire que du jour au
lendemain
l'administration américaine décide que
l'ensemble des entreprises dans le monde
entier et notamment les entreprises
européennes n'ont plus le droit de
commercer avec l'iran et donc les
entreprises européennes se retrouvent un
peu entre le marteau et l'enclume
d'un côté leurs droits propres à elles
ont la possibilité de commercer avec
l'iran mais les américains les en
empêche
avec des sanctions à la clé qui sont
extrêmement extrêmement importante et
récemment il ya eu d'autres menacés ce
qui explique sans doute la mobilisation
des des européens avec les menaces de
sanctions sur vous les montrer dans le
reportage sur north stream de north
stream 2 c'est le pape line le projet de
parc lann entre la russie et l'allemagne
où là les américains et que ce soit
d'ailleurs côté démocrates comme
républicains
je pense qu'on va peut-être en reparler
mais l'arrivée de l'administration baden
enfin il faut pas que les européens
pensent que parce que là il va ya voir
l'arrivée des démocrates
les sanctions et cette force de
projection
l'utilisation du droit comme une arme
dans la guerre économique va va
s'arrêter et d'ailleurs là là là là là
là où les lois extraterritoriales ont
pris leur ampleur et là où il ya eu les
les plus fortes sanctions contre les
entreprises européennes je pense
notamment bnp paribas en 2015
10 milliards de dollars la banque
française a été condamné sur le
fondement des lois extraterritoriales
par les américains à 10 milliards de
dollars
et c'était sous l'administration obama
donc il faut une séquence pardonnez-moi
des conséquences très lourdes sur les
finances de ces entreprises européennes
et françaises
et pourtant une réciproque qui n'est pas
vrai on est trop tendre en europe
justement avec les états unis on ne sait
pas assez défendu et on ne sait pas si
défendu c'est à dire que on a en a une
volonté il ya une une volonté politique
notamment qui est affichée par le
président macro 1,2 de rétablir cette
cette souveraineté française européenne
c'est cette politique d'indépendance ce
qu'a affiché aujourd'hui le parlement
européen va exactement dans cette ligne
mais là maintenant ce qu'il faut c'est
que on met en place des outils au
service de cette politique
d'indépendance et donc il faut que ça se
fait que deux dans le cadre national il
faut qu'on prenne des mesures aussi au
parlement français mais surtout il faut
que entre européens ont su nice plus et
on met en place ces outils pour lutter
de manière défensive pour mieux produire
donnez moi bien sûr c'est une intention
de beaucoup de deux européens et
français ont mais regardez l'expérience
1 française des gaffes à bruno le maire
l'a qui essaient de faire tout même
bouger les choses à ce niveau là et c
c'est très compliqué souvent au niveau
européen on a du mal à se coordonner
extrêmement compliqué mais les choses
avancent c'est un premier pas les choses
avancent mais bien sûr c'est extrêmement
compliqué parce que les européens sont
souvent divisés et notamment les
américains utilisent nos divisions
contre ça et donc ce qu'il faut c'est
que ben il faut il faut continuer à
avancer il faut s'unir et mettre en
place mettre en place un jeu vous donner
un exemple
en 1998 c'était pas sous
l'administration c'était de
l'administration clinton qui avait mis
en place des nouvelles sanctions là
c'était pas l'iran c'était pas la russie
et cuba et à cette époque les leaks
d'europe 1 a été uni les européens
étaient unis et avait mis en place
le règlement de 1998 qui était une
réponse juridique à ces sanctions
extraterritoriale et bien à l'époque les
américains avaient reculé donc vous vous
rappelez - unis aujourd'hui on a du mal
de plus en plus à s'unir pardon comment
vous expliquer qu'on est de plus en plus
de mal justement à s'unir qui est autant
de dissensions au niveau européen soit
les temps ont changé depuis la date que
vous me citez oui non pas tout
simplement parce qu'on sait que par
exemple en allemagne l'allemagne avait
très très peur des sanctions contre son
industrie automobile et donc été
extrêmement réticente à s'unir avec les
français pour lutter faire face et peser
contre les américains c'était aussi la
même chose avec les anglais qui avait
une tradition beaucoup plus atlantiste
exclamé les choses chance
les choses avancent et notamment ce qui
s'est passé aujourd'hui au parlement au
parlement européen
je pense que c'est une très très bonne
chose en tout cas il ya cette volonté
politique une nouvelle volonté politique
au niveau européen
et maintenant il faut faire un pas de
plus avancées et mettre en place que je
vous dise et ses outils au niveau
français comme européen
merci beaucoup raphaël gauvin gauvin un
député la reine 5e circonscription de
saône-et-loire merci d'avoir été avec
nous en direct sur rtl